[Applaus]
diese Wohnung habe ich in Deutschland
für 150.000 Euro gekauft aber wie wohnt
man am anderen Ende der Welt wie wohnt
man günstig vs teuer also wirklich teuer
in Bangkok time
unser erstes Apartment liegt mitten in
der Stadt an der sukum Beat road in der
Mega Metropole Bangkok was die
Hauptstadt von Thailand und wer dachte
man kann in so einer mega Metropole nur
für sehr viel Geld leben wird in diesem
Video vom Gegenteil überzeugt denn was
wir hier in Bangkok für 350 € bekommen
ist völlig verrückt weil wir können much
[Musik]
aber wie sieht die Wohnung
unglaublich grundsätzlich muss man sagen
die Wohnung ist unheimlich Smart geplant
klein aber doch irgendwie sehr geräumig
und offen hell schickt modern und das
ganze ohne Schnickschnack und perfekt um
mit dem Koffer anzukommen und direkt
einziehen zu können weil die Wohnung
eben fertig eingerichtet ist oder ist
sie dies ist
kein Hase Justin Marcel that von
experience bevor wir aber genau dazu
kommen und uns anschauen wie man für den
20-fachen Preis in 50 Stock in einem
Penthouse in Bangkok wohnt erstmal zu
dem Teil des günstigen Hauses der ist
wirklich so unvorstellbar macht das
Ganze für 350 € mieten zu können am Topf
gepflegten Garten und dem voll
ausgestatteten vorbei deren Nutzung
natürlich im Preis inbegriffen ist ab in
den fünften Stock Rui haben die facility
auf Blogs
[Musik]
es ist unglaublich wir haben einen
großen Pool 5 Stock mitten in der Stadt
es wird sich um alles gekümmert es ist
wirklich unvorstellbar was man hier für
sein Geld also ich ich komme wirklich
nicht drauf klar in der Umrechnung ist
das wirklich unglaublich dieses
Apartment mit dem Pool auf dem fünften
Stock mit einem Konzert unten
abgeriegelt mit Sicherheit mit Schranke
in dieser Lage an der Zukunft kostet
83000 € im Kauf das finde ich richtig
krank und das lässt einen so ein
bisschen zweifeln ob man nicht doch mal
für ein Jahr für zwei Deutschland
verlässt und das hier einfach super
günstig mitnimmt
weniger als die Hälfte des Geldes was
ich fürs Wohnungsprojekt ausgegeben habe
eine fertige voll eingerichtete Wohnung
kaufen zu können ist völlig verrückt
einer der Hauptgründe warum ich eine
Wohnung gekauft habe und warum ich das
Thema so sehr interessiert das wird
überall auf der Welt schauen wo man für
wie viel Geld lebt ist dass mir die IDE
gefallen hat mich mit einer Immobilie
langfristig abzusichern Vorsorge für
schlechtere Tage ist unheimlich wichtig
und um für schlechtere Tage vorzusorgen
muss man nicht gleich eine Wohnung
kaufen und diese aufwendig renovieren
das ganze geht durch klagt den Partner
des heutigen Videos auch deutlich
einfacher und günstiger ich bin
selbstständig was passiert also wenn ich
mich beispielsweise genau auf so einer
produktionsreise verletze um einen
Unfall habe was passiert wenn ich mich
langfristig psychisch erkranke und nicht
mehr arbeiten genau in solchen Fällen
greift der
Berufsunfähigkeitsversicherung die mich
genau für solche Situationen Absicht
jeder von uns ist in der
unterschiedlichen Situationen und
glücklicherweise gibt es für alle von
uns durch die persönliche Beratung bei
Clark die passende und richtige Lösung
es geht darum sich Gedanken zu machen
bevor es zu spät ist für heute morgen
oder in 10 Jahren hast du vollen
Überblick über alle deine laufenden
Verträge und in einer App dein
Ansprechpartner für Schadenfälle
kündigungswünsche und
Versicherungsvergleiche immer mit dabei
bleiben das ganze komplett digital aber
trotzdem mit echten kompetenten
Versicherungsexperte mit dem Code Dave
oder über diesen QR-Code erhaltet ihr
durch das Hochladen von bestehenden
Versicherungen bis zu 45 Euro als best
choice Gutscheine super vielen part
einlösen könnt darunter about you Media
Markt oder im App Store lasst euch jetzt
kostenfrei beraten und sichert euch ab
vielen Dank an klagt fürs möglich machen
dieses Videos und euch viel Spaß weiter
mit dem Video und jetzt von der
günstigen Wohnung an der sukum wie Brot
zu den Reichen und schön in die
Millennium residence
zweites Apartment in Bangkok 50
ja also wirklich eine riesen Wohnung
mega das hier das für uns hinbekommen
hat und die zeigen euch jetzt
willkommen im absoluten top-apartment
324 Quadratmetern 49 Stock in Bangkok in
einem sehr guten viertel insgesamt
besteht dieser gesamte Bereich aus 4
Tauern komplett abgesichert mit Security
mit Schranken und so weiter und das
Ganze ist Penthouse also wirklich echtes
Penthouse 360° außen rum Fenster
komplett vom Fußboden bis zur Decke dann
Balkone in alle Richtungen vier
Schlafzimmer vier Bäder und eine Menge
Menge Menge Platz
hier im Eingangsbereich direkt rechts
vom Eingangsbereich haben wir einen sehr
großen Essbereich eine Tafel für
insgesamt 14 Leute mit einem Fernseher
eingebaut super schick hochqualitativ
eingerichtet man kann super einfach alle
Vorhänge zu und aufmachen man fühlt sich
super wohl also ein mega Apartment Dave
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
großen Wohn- und Essbereich insgesamt
haben wir zwei Küchen dazu aber gleich
noch mal mehr ein großer Wohnbereich
Fenster in alle Richtungen das Highlight
für mich hatten wir so auch noch nicht
eine Bar die nicht nur im vorderen
Bereich alles hat was man braucht
sondern einen Walk in Weinkeller also
hier kann Wein gelagert werden bis zum
get now wir haben noch einen großen
Weinkühler wo der Wein wirklich auf
Temperatur gehalten werden kann hier
kann gelagert werden das ist ein
absolutes Highlight okay sorry have
small like Office area little Studio you
over the park white here Banja Kitty
park and this not forgetation
und das hier ist Küche Nummer 1 die
Küche in der das Essen präsentiert
werden kann hier wird relativ wenig
gekocht und alles was wirklich an Kochen
passiert in der hinteren Küche damit das
ein bisschen abgetrennt vom großen
Wohnbereich ist durch den großen Flur am
Essbereich am großen Balkon in Richtung
Stadt vorbei am Eingangsbereich vorbei
geht es quasi genau auf die andere Seite
die genauso groß ist wie der Wohnbereich
zu allen Zimmern auf der rechten Seite
starten wir direkt mit einem kleinen
aber feinen Zimmer ich glaube das ist
das kleinste Schlafzimmer mit kleinem
Arbeitsbereich einem kleinen Bett und
Blick in Richtung Stadt dann geht es
hier hinten weiter in den
hauptschlafbereich der linken Seite ein
Kinderzimmer in Richtung Park auf der
rechten Seite ein Kinderzimmer Richtung
Stadt riesengroß und direkt connected
mit dem Elternschlafzimmer den Master
Bedroom
[Musik]
alles wunderbar alles sehr groß super
schick und von hier geht es ins Bad und
sweet wir haben eine freistehende
Badewanne an den großen Fenstern in
Richtung Stadt mega schick zwei
Waschbecken an den Waschbecken vorbei
einmal in die bodentiefe Dusche und
einmal zur Toilette und das absolute
Highlight von hier aus geht es in den
man kann es fast an Kleider Apartment
nennen es ist
riesengroß wir haben Schränke zu allen
Seiten beleuchtet genug Platz für
Taschen für Schuhe es ist so viel Platz
dass in der Mitte so eine typische
Recamiere steht um sich Schuhe
anzuziehen um sich hinzusetzen beim
Anziehen wir haben wieder einen Ausblick
nach draußen auf den Park also wirklich
das hier ist top top notch und auch hier
in der teuren Wohnung gibt es natürlich
eine Menge Freizeitangebot direkt im
Preis mit inbegriffen Jim und so weiter
ist in einem extra Haus in einem extra
Bereich weil der gesamte Bereich eben
aus vier verschiedenen Gebäuden besteht
und so alle an einem Ort zusammenkommen
können für den Pool für den Gym und fürs
Gym und so weiter
hier ein riesen Pool groß genug um
wirklich Bahn zu schwimmen also riesen
Fitnessstudio das werden wir euch
wahrscheinlich nicht zeigen können da
sind eine Menge Leute gerade zugange
aber der Pool das ist schon richtig
richtig geil das Wetter ist das ganze
Jahr in Bangkok halt so dass du ins
Wasser gehen kannst heute okay in
Bangkok
crazy in the middle of really big
buildings hier ein bisschen tenniscord
ja also vollwertiger Tennisplatz in
Mitten dieser riesen Metropole da oben
irgendwo am 50 Stock haben wir gerade
uns die Wohnung angeguckt unglaublich
in this kind of United about to hand and
fifty parties
also eine Monatsmiete von 6700 €
thank you so much really really great
apartment und hier auch noch mal ein
riesen Danke schön am property Scout und
besonders am Pierre der uns die Wohnung
gezeigt hat der das alles für uns
organisiert hat falls ihr irgendwas in
Bangkok sucht zum Boden zu mieten zum
kaufen was auch immer alle Links sind in
der Videobeschreibung die werden euch
helfen und haben für alle von euch die
richtige Wohnung parat ich weiß nicht
wie viele Leute von euch wirklich nach
Bangkok ziehen wollen aber bei dem
Preisen könnte ich mir das schon
vorstellen wenn ich das Video gefallen
hat lasst ihn gerne ein Like da vergesst
nicht den Kanal zu abonnieren und
natürlich bei der Agentur von Pierre und
seinen Kollegen vorbei zu schauen
macht's gut bis zum nächsten Mal
[Musik]